- So you turned 50
this year, right?
Or you just turned 50.
It's so interesting to me
that people can't project or
understand what the
market is moving.
A.K.A. in this scenario that
we as 50-year-olds, I'm 40.
You as 50-year-olds are gonna
live dramatically longer and
healthier than your parents' and
grandparents' generation so you
sit here at 50 and as a child
what you grew up with you start
realizing where am I in my life?
Middle, tail end to middle and
so many of your entrepreneurial
and just life
ambitions start to dwindle.
You start settling in
to this is my life,
this is how it played out.
I could have, I should have
and what I'd wish is that
why am I making this video?
I'm probably making it for my
50 year-old self so
Hey Gary, 50 year-old self.
Yeah, you used to have hair.
What I hope to accomplish with
this one piece of content is to
inspire one 49, 50,
51-year-old to understand
psst you have a lot
more time than you think.
It is super appropriate for
you to start that business
that you've always
wanted right now.
It is actually quite practical
you probably have a much deeper
understanding of what to do to
be successful than the average
25-year-old that's rolling into
my office looking for dollars to
start their business
'cause they've got an idea.
If I could just take the energy
in my heart to deploy it into so
many people brains to understand
how much time,
how much time is
still left in your life
to do your thing
that would make me very happy.
That would make me so happy
because I do believe as I'm
spending a lot of time, maybe
I'm affected by my last 15, 20
hangouts with such age group
individuals way too many people
are starting to plot their exit.
Their unwind and I'm like
Jesus you may have 50,
that's right with modern medicine,
you may have 50 more
good years of executing,
40 for sure.
I really think knock on wood so
many of you watching this have
40 full, big years.
Think back to when you were 10
from that moment 'til right now
all that life you've got on the
backend and people are trying to
wind down and figure out how
they're going to slow it down or
wrap it up.
Fuck wrapping it up, man.
Start it up.
You're just 50.